I'm sitting here this is great Beastie
Boys thank you so much for being here
first of all I won't ask you about a
couple things first of all you have this
tour there's been this tour going that's
for a while now and you have an
interesting opening act on the tour that
one might not expect let's talk about
that it's not actually a tour where it's
a traveling pageant a traveling pageant
yeah I'm sorry I misspoke a traveling
pageant yeah and tell us how the pageant
begins so hence the opening act
hence the opening act which is a dog
show so you have a dog show yeah not
like a competition where you know best
of breed it's like a bunch of dogs
actually that rescue dogs right and Bob
Moore right he's amazing mongrels he
rescues these dogs from shelters where
awful things might sure happen it sure
he rescues them and then to the dogs do
any kind of performance do they do they
have tricks today oh yes oh yeah tight
ropes oh sorry yeah tight ropes I mean
they it's it's heart-stopping high jumps
jump through hoops this is incredible
stuff does the audience know this is
going to happen or they momentarily
stunned or you know they've come to see
the Beastie Boys they've come to the
pageant as it were and then dogs are on
stage and they're doing tricks is there
yeah there's usually a couple people
that are a little confused but then they
you know which sets it sets the tone
right right I think it sounds fantastic
so I'm cities oh you'd be surprised a
real dog lover cities Denver for
instance dogs were big so they go crazy
for the dog someone screamed Fifi sucks
someone screamed that at a dog clearly
not a big dog City Seattle maybe they
knew that particular dog and knew that
that dog you know was a bad dog maybe if
he's the star of the show right right
jumping the high thing she climbs up the
ladder and the hold on there's no room
for that kind of hate I don't think
especially it's ridiculous it's wrong
yeah maybe you can investigate it a hate
crime against dogs I don't well I'd be
the one to do that so I'll look right
into that
clearly now I want to ask you about this
and this is you guys are we're probably
roughly the same age I'm in my late 50s
and now we're roughly I'm guessing were
roughly the same age and you guys are
still going yes we're still yeah child
I'm a child but you have managed to stay
relevant you're going strong you know
around 40 years of age did you think
that that was possible do you ever think
about it at all when you were twenty
twenty-one and and rapping or it never
occurred to you you never thought about
it so what you think I mean it's one of
those things where there's no reason
until the Rolling Stones started touring
you know well into there they're in
their 70s now and they're great they
still are doing it you know it's awkward
what's that little awkward for them yeah
it is getting awkward for them my job
here is to trick you into saying one
thing you way to regret my job is done
well it is an amazing thrill to have you
guys on the show thank you so much we
appreciate it you're done I'm going to
commercial and then we're coming back
for a 40-minute interview he's gonna be
on PBS this is part of the American
masters series yes
the only time we've ever been
interviewed we played songs on shows we
never we've only been interviewed by
Joan Rivers on the Joan Rivers show
you're the Joe Franklin show oh yeah
that is incredible time that's amazing
your New York you know Joe Fred well I'm
from Boston originally director
clearly this interview is over now you
never would have come on if you know
house from Boston huge thanks thank you
for being here to the five boroughs go
out and get it Beastie Boys paget
Brewster
[Applause]